let us now revisit the variants and see
what happens in the case of independence
variances have some general properties
that we have already seen however since
we often add random variables we would
like to be able to say something about
the variance of the sum of two random
variables unfortunately the situation is
not so simple and in general the
variance of the sum is not the same as
the sum of the variances we will see an
example shortly on the other hand when x
and y are independent the variance of
the sum is equal to the sum of the
variances and this is a very useful fact
let us go through the derivation of this
property but to keep things simple let
us assume just for the sake of the
derivation that the two random variables
have zero mean so in that case the
variance of the sum is just the expected
value of the square of the sum and we
can expand the quadratic and write this
as expectation of x squared plus 2xy
plus y squared then we use linearity of
expectations to write this as expected
value of x squared plus twice the
expected value of x times y and then
plus the expected value of y squared now
the first term is just the variance of X
because we have assumed that we have
zero mean the last term is similarly the
variance of Y how about the middle term
because of independence the expected
value of the product
is the same as the product of the
expected values and the expected values
are zero in our case so this term
because of independence this term is
going to be equal to zero in particular
what we have is that the expected value
of XY equals the expected value of x
times the expected value of y equal to
zero and so we have verified that indeed
the variance of the sum is equal to the
sum of the variances let us now look at
some examples suppose that X is the same
random variable as Y clearly this is a
case where independence fails to hold if
I tell you the value of X then you know
the value of y so in this case the
variance of the sum is the same as the
variance of twice X since X is the same
as Y X plus y is 2 times X and then
using this property for the variance
what happens when we multiply by a
constant this is going to be 4 times the
variance of X in another example suppose
that X is the negative of Y in that case
X plus y is identically equal to 0 so
we're dealing with a random variable
that takes a constant value in
particular it is always equal to its
mean and so the difference from the mean
is always equal to 0 and so the variance
will also evaluate to 0 so we see that
the variance of the sum can take quite
different values depending on the sort
of inter relation that we have between
the two random variables so these two
examples indicate that knowing the
variance of each one of the random
variables is not enough to say much
about the variance of the sum the answer
will generally depend on how the two
random variables are related to each
other and what kind of dependencies they
have as the last example suppose now
that x and y are independent x is
independent from
why and therefore X is also independent
from minus three-y therefore this
variance is equal to the sum of the
variances of X and of minus 3y and using
the fact that we already know this is
going to be equal to the variance of X
plus 9 times the variance of Y as an
illustration of the usefulness of the
property of the variance that we have
just established we will now use it to
calculate the variance of a binomial
random variable remember that a binomial
with parameters N and P corresponds to
the number of successes in n independent
trials we use indicator variables this
is the same trick that we use to
calculate the expected value of the
binomial so the random variable X sub I
is equal to 1 if the eyes trial is a
success in this is 0 otherwise and as we
did before we note that X the total
number of successes is the sum of those
indicator variables each success makes
one of those variables equal to 1 so by
adding those indicator variables were
just counting the number of successes
the key point to note is that the
assumption of Independence that we're
making is essentially the assumption
that these random variables X I are
independent of each other so we're
dealing with a situation where we have a
sum of independent random variables and
according to what we have shown the
variance of X is going to be the sum of
the variances of the x i's
now the X eyes all have the same
distribution
so all these variances will be the same
it suffices to consider one of them now
x1 is a Bernoulli random variable with
parameter P we know what it's variance
is it is P times 1 minus P and therefore
this is the formula for the variance of
a binomial random variable